hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in section 3 of the groundwork of the
metaphysics of morals can't ask a
question that may at first strike you as
very strange especially if you've read
through the rest of the work mainly how
is a categorical imperative possible why
is that a strange question well he's
already talked an awful lot about the
categorical imperative not merely as
possible but it's something actual for
us something that we are bound by and if
we want to consider ourselves to be
moral human beings must recognize and
obey as well as give to ourselves so why
is he talking about it being possible
and asking questions about it he's not
asking whether it's possible that that's
already granted he wants to understand
how how is it that something like this
could come about and that's going to be
very helpful because it allows us to
sort of locate where it's coming from
and what it cannot be coming from he's
done this already to some degree in
talking about the different other
proposed principles of morality that
turned out to be as he calls them
heteronomous autonomy which I don't have
on the board but is a very important
term that he uses here is critical and
as opposed to any sort of heteronomy on
the will so let's talk about what he
goes over in this section again he
distinguishes between a world of sense
and a world of the understanding or the
intelligible world uses these fairly
synonymously rightly so and within the
world of sense we see ourselves as
beings that do in fact carry out actions
but these actions are effects or is
going to call them phenomena of the will
which is a free causality not something
that we can directly observe through
experience in the world of sense so it
not something that is say the object of
science you know or the object of
empirical observation but rather it's a
free causality and he's discussed this
quite a bit in other places so you can
look at the other videos talking about
that
and so the will as frequently is part of
the intelligible world why is that
important well insofar he says as our
actions are stemming from this will this
free causality the actions themselves
are effects determined by that cause
however we understand ourselves as
phenomenal beings as beings that have
desires and inclinations as well all of
us have these we have a whole panoply of
desires and inclinations these can be
anything under the Sun that's why I
can't says at another place that you
can't really determine what happiness is
because it's a satisfaction of desires
and inclinations there's so many of them
who knows you know what which ones any
given human being has however these
desires and inclinations they can also
determine our actions when we're
following along by say a psychological
determinism when we're behaving in
immoral or non moral ways we're allowing
desires and inclinations to you might
say run the show to to make the final
decision about what we're going to do
and Khan says that we can even talk
about a law or laws plural of desires
and inclinations these are exactly
what's a psychological laws are supposed
to be they pertain to the phenomenal
human being as somebody who has desires
motivations and clinicians all these
sorts of things that are non moral non
moral and content which can in fact
guide our actions so we're to a certain
extent torn between these two worlds the
intelligible world is the place where we
are going to you know find motivations
of morality according to cut the world
of sense is where we are going to find
motive
patience of happiness of you know
satisfaction of our desires and
inclinations Kant says and both of those
can move us both of those can determine
what our actions are going to be but the
will in its fullest sense is on the side
where we find morality what else does he
tell us that's very important about this
he says that this intelligible world is
in fact the ground of the sensible world
the world of sense and the laws of the
intelligible world are in a certain
sense you know greater-than or grounding
for the world of sense as well so here
we go the world of understanding
contains the foundation or ground or
however we want to conceive of it of the
world of sense consequently has laws
also and accordingly give the law to my
will so my will as free can't do just
whatever it wants and remain free
there's laws given to it in the
intelligible world you might say okay
where do those come from Khan tells us
from reason reason is also on the side
of the intelligible as opposed to the
sensible and the Faculty of reason is
precisely what gives to us these laws
allowing them these laws for the will
allowing them to become imperatives like
the categorical imperative right
imperatives tell us what to do following
those imperatives leads to actions as
duties as what it is that the imperative
requires of us now Conte distinguishes
between several different kinds of
imperatives
there are imperatives also on this side
imperatives that have to do with
satisfying our desires and inclinations
imperatives of happiness and imperatives
of prudence or of skill right the
imperative of prudence leads to
happiness imperatives of skill say if
you want to accomplish this then do this
those are all condition those are all
hypothetical those they'll say well if
you happen to have this bunch of desires
and inclinations then do this a
categorical imperative says no do this
do at do actions that conform to this
way of doing them so for example act
only on the maximum you can will to be a
universal law of nature first
formulation of the categorical
imperative notice it doesn't say if you
so happen to be moved by these
inclinations and desires no it doesn't
say anything like that it says here's
what you need to do buddy no matter what
situation you happen to be in act
according to the maxim that you can will
to be a universal law of nature or you
know act always so as to treat humanity
and your person and that of others
always as an end never merely as they
mean second formulation of the
categorical imperative right doesn't say
if you just so happen to want to do that
but in act that way or if you're made in
such a way is that's you know what you
like no or if you want to stay out of
trouble kind of thing do that and then
is coming from reason that is coming
from reason providing imperatives so why
is this so important well we as human
beings we exist on both sides we live in
both the intelligible world which we
can't actually know and the world of
sense and this is where we can have
conflicts we can find ourselves having a
hard time doing what it is that we're
bid to do by reason precisely because
our desires and inclinations are strong
and here is where Kant says something
quite interesting he says that that even
people who uses examples right even
people who are kind of screwed up people
who
are in you know moved by their their
desires and inclinations primarily can
recognize that they ought to obey the
categorical imperative he says there's
no one not even the worst villain
provided that he is otherwise accustomed
to the use of reason who when we give
him examples of people behaving properly
what are some examples honesty of
purpose steadfastness and following good
Maxim's sympathy and general benevolence
even combined with great sacrifices of
advantage and comfort nobody he says
does not wish it so long as he's
reasonable that he possessed those
qualities on account of the inclinations
and desires he can't actually make
himself desire them effectively or put
them into practice but he can recognize
there's something wrong there's
something missing where does that come
from that comes from the fact that he or
she as a free being has this side just
so happens that this side isn't calling
the shots
isn't determining things instead the
stuff on this side is but they're still
able to recognize it concepts so what we
have here again and asking how is a
categorical imperative possible it comes
about precisely by the fact that we
straddle these two sides these two
integrated sides of ourselves and we we
have this Faculty of reason that can
tell our will here's how you need to
behave if you really want to be free and
you want to continue being a free being
a free cause you should follow these
imperatives and then we have to do them
in reality so you know if you think
about what it means to actually enact
the categorical imperative it's one
thing to formulate it for yourself and
and you know the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals you know first
formulation act only on the maximum that
you can will at the same time to be
universal law of nature nice right now
do it in practice
well that is where you enter the world
of sense that is where the categorical
imperative is as something possible
intruding into actuality so this is very
important you might say side discussion
going on in con that helps to illuminate
for us how it is that we're able to have
categorical imperatives